[Música]
el ejército de Israel mató a tres
jóvenes palestinos en cisjordania
ocupada en el año más mortífero para los
palestinos de los territorios ocupados y
en el día internacional de solidaridad
con el pueblo palestino cuando se
cumplen 75 años de la resolución de la
ONU que contemplaba la creación de un
estado judío y un estado árabe en
Palestina
jornada cargada de diplomacia en torno a
la guerra en Ucrania dos cumbres de alto
nivel debate en la invasión rusa reunida
en Rumanía la otan mantiene su apoyo a
kiev y en Alemania miembros del g7
condenan los crímenes de guerra en
territorio ucraniano Tenemos reporte
desde Berlín
[Música]
en Estados Unidos la Corte Suprema
revisa el orden de prioridades de
deportación decretado por la
administración vaiden que se centra en
las personas culpables de crímenes
graves El Ejecutivo demócrata cambió lo
estipulado por Donald Trump y
gobernadores republicanos han llevado
Este cambio ante los tribunales
ampliamos desde Washington
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
hoy 29 de noviembre se conmemora el día
internacional de solidaridad con el
pueblo de Palestina hace 75 años la
asamblea general de la ONU aprobó la
resolución que estipulaba la creación de
un estado judío y un estado árabe en
Palestina El Aniversario llega en un
momento de recrudecimiento del conflicto
derivado de la ocupación israelí este
2022 está siendo el año más mortífero
para los palestinos de los territorios
ocupados desde Jerusalén nuestra
corresponsal Yanira Gómez con los
detalles
en 1947 la ONU resolvió la partición de
Palestina para crear un estado judío y
otro árabe pero 75 años después la idea
de un estado palestino no podría estar
más lejos algunos de los motivos los dio
a Antonio Gutiérrez en su mensaje por el
día internacional de solidaridad con el
pueblo palestino el secretario general
de la ONU dijo que la esperanza de una
paz se ve imposibilitada por la
ocupación israelí la expansión de los
asentamientos ilegales las demoliciones
y desalojos de poblaciones palestinas
así como el bloqueo en caza y las
muertes de civiles palestinos en
cisjordania Aunque la visión de la
solución de dos estados en la que se
apoya la ONU se ha convertido en una
invocación manida sin objetivos claros
esta enumeración de Gutiérrez es la
violencia diaria en el terreno hoy por
ejemplo tres jóvenes palestinos dos de
ellos eran hermanos murieron cerca de
ramala y hebrón por fuego del ejército
israelí en un año que se ha convertido
en el más mortífero desde 2006 y en el
que el gobierno israelí acomoda a
formarse no augura que esto vaya a
cambiar las negociaciones entre Benjamin
netan Yahoo y sus aliados están
derivando en que políticos israelíes de
extrema derecha y antiárabes tengan
mayor poder de decisión sobre los
territorios palestinos ocupados algo que
grupos de Derechos Humanos como pignaut
temen que derive en una eventual anexión
total en paralelo a esto el Primer
Ministro israelí saliente ya es lapiz
instó a 50 países a votar en contra de
que la ONU pida la Corte Internacional
de Justicia una opinión sobre los
efectos de la ocupación y las acciones
de Israel que rige Y controla por
completo la vida de los palestinos
y en otras noticias hoy es una jornada
cargada de diplomacia en torno a la
guerra en Ucrania por un lado la Cumbre
de los ministros de exteriores de los
países miembros de la otan en bucarest
rumania ha girado en torno al envío a
kiev de más ayuda militar y de
asistencia para reconstruir la
infraestructura devastada por otro lado
los ministros de Justicia del g7 se
encontraron en Alemania algunos de los
miembros del grupo de las siete mayores
potencias del mundo entre las que se
cuenta también Rusia condenaron los
crímenes de guerra cometidos en Ucrania
nuestro corresponsal en berlina Thomas
Sparrow nos amplía la ayuda que recibe
Ucrania de parte de los países del g7 y
muy de manera particular de parte de
Alemania que este año preside el grupo
no se limita solamente a la cooperación
política a la ayuda económica o incluso
al envío de armamento también como quedó
claro en una reunión de los ministros de
justicia de eje 7 en Alemania esa
cooperación con Ucrania se extenderá a
la investigación de posibles crímenes de
guerra cometidos por las fuerzas
militares rusas como parte de su
invasión de Ucrania como explicaron los
ministros de Justicia que atendieron
esta reunión esa cooperación se
extenderá en primer lugar a la
recopilación de pruebas Más allá de
Ucrania en Ucrania ya Hay un
procedimiento en curso para recolectar
pruebas pero esas pruebas también pueden
recolectarse por ejemplo entre los
migrantes entre los refugiados que
dejaron Ucrania y se instalaron por
ejemplo en países como Alemania en
Alemania se estima que alrededor de un
millón de refugiados ucranianos la
cooperación también se refiere a una
posible coordinación entre los
diferentes países del g7 en la
recolección de pruebas se espera que se
genere un punto de contacto en cada de
los países para evitar duplicación en la
recolección de información se trata sin
duda de un desafío muy importante de
parte del g7 un desafío muy importante
también de parte de Alemania y es un
desafío que puede tardar un buen tiempo
en la medida que los diferentes países
Ucrania en particular pero también los
países del g7 trabajan conjuntamente en
la búsqueda de pruebas para identificar
posibles crímenes de guerra el
presidente de Francia Emmanuel macrón
llegará esta noche a Estados Unidos en
su Segunda visita de estado a Washington
donde ya fue invitado en 2018 por Donald
Trump en un contexto internacional
bastante distinto al de Entonces los
mandatarios aliados discutirán
cuestiones que van desde la cooperación
en materia de seguridad hasta las
discrepancias en materia económica
una invitación que es señal de buen
momento entre ambas naciones Emmanuel
Llegará el martes por la noche a
Washington para un viaje de tres días
con mucha pompa Esta visita es la
segunda invitación que recibe desde 2018
cuando lo invitó Donald Trump esta será
la primera visita de estado de la
Administración biden Harris pondrá de
relieve la profunda y duradera relación
entre Estados Unidos y Francia nuestro
más antiguo Aliado que se basa en los
valores democráticos que compartimos los
vínculos económicos y la cooperación en
materia de defensa y seguridad la
cuestión económica estará en el centro
de las conversaciones la ley de
reducción de la inflación firmada por el
presidente biden preocupa a Europa que
denuncia el proteccionismo
estadounidense parece esperar limitar
las medidas destinadas a repatriar a
Estados Unidos las inversiones
industriales vinculadas con la
transición energética los temas
espaciales
similares también serán tratados la
última etapa del viaje será Nueva
Orleans la ciudad fundada por el francés
donde se hablara de la francofonía el
encuentro diplomático también contará
con una escena de estado de centenas de
personas en la cual participará la
delegación francesa compuesta por varios
ministros parlamentarios y
personalidades además de una acogida muy
especial se espera de este viaje que
Emanuel McQueen pueda hablar en nombre
de toda la Unión Europea
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque la
Corte Suprema empieza hoy el proceso de
revisión de las prioridades de
deportación estipuladas por la
administración de Joe biden centradas en
expulsar del país a los extranjeros
culpables de crímenes graves esto es un
cambio respecto a la ley impuesta por
Donald Trump el que los gobernadores
republicanos de Texas y Luisiana
llevaron ante el tribunal nuestro
corresponsal en Washington Cristóbal
Vázquez nos amplía
la Corte Suprema de Justicia de mayoría
conservadora empieza hoy a escuchar
argumentos del ejecutivo Es decir de la
administración de Joe biden sobre las
prioridades que tiene la patrulla
fronteriza las los encargados de vigilar
la frontera de Estados Unidos con México
las prioridades que tendrán a la hora de
determinar Quiénes son deportados y
Quienes no eso es lo que se está en este
momento debatiendo y
en la Corte Suprema de Justicia qué
prioridades van a tener estos agentes
fronterizos a la hora de determinar a
quienes puede demandar inmediatamente o
a quienes le da la oportunidad de pues
tener un proceso de asilo en este país
lo que argumentan los
y Alejandro mallorca hacia el secretario
de seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos
es que dada el límite de recursos que
tiene pues se tiene que enfocar entonces
la fuerza pública en las personas que
representan una amenaza una amenaza para
la seguridad de Estados Unidos Esas son
las personas que pues la patrulla
fronteriza y los oficiales de la
frontera tienen que enfocarse para
deportar y no al resto de inmigrantes
Texas y Luisiana sin embargo estados
republicanos pues han apelado y han
contrademandado esta decisión y estos
protocolos de que aquí ha propuesto la
administración de Joe biden diciendo que
lo que quieren ellos es tener la
libertad la discreción de poder
deportar a cualquier persona que no sea
legal en este país Alejandro mallorca
dice que Estados Unidos Simplemente no
tiene los recursos para deportar a más
de 11 millones de indocumentados en este
país y hay que Resaltar que esta
decisión se conocerá en julio del
próximo año durante dos semanas las
fuerzas iraníes han atacado a los grupos
de la oposición kurda iraní con sede en
Irak Teherán acusa a estos grupos de
orquestar las protestas masivas
desatadas por la muerte de maxamney al
mismo tiempo Turquía también ha
intensificado sus ataques contra grupos
kurdos tanto en Irak como en Siria
nuestros corresponsales están en el
kurdistán iraki y han hablado con
civiles afectados por los bombardeos
la ciudad de coya está en calma pero La
amenaza nunca está lejos Irán ataca
regularmente la base del partido
democrático del kurdistán iraní estos
ataques han matado a varios civiles
incluida la esposa embarazada de este
pez merga combatiente armado kurdo
estaba lejos de la base pero
bombardearon justo en medio del
campamento eran viviendas donde vivían
mujeres y niños no estaban armados ni
eran militares herido el mismo en el
ataque se encuentra en un lugar que
quiere mantener en secreto tras el
último ataque de hace una semana los
familiares de los pez mergas se
dispersaron surux de 7 años vivía en el
campamento a menudo dibuja el ataque a
su escuela que fue atacada a finales de
septiembre
Aquí están los misiles que bombardearon
nuestra escuela un misil destrozó
nuestra escuela y los alumnos huyeron no
hay nadie allí desde el ataque no tuve
miedo no soy un niño que tenga miedo
los ataques y Daniels no solo afectan a
los civiles vinculados a los grupos
armados el pueblo de armota albergaba a
250 familias casi todas han huido este
domingo los bancos de la Iglesia
Católica permanecieron vacíos y ya no se
celebraron servicios
le gustaría que la situación se
resolviera Y que todos los actores
externos o internos respetarán a esta
nación como a todas las demás en todo el
curdistan iraquí y la exasperaciones
similar en el valle de nala aquí el
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán el pkk se enfrenta al ejército
Turco según los informes 15 civiles han
muerto a causa de los ataques aéreos
turcos desde principios de año en el
kurdistán iraquí
se trata de un enfrentamiento entre el
pkk y Turquía en la región Así que
podemos decir que Turquía y el pkk son
responsables pero el gobierno debe
expulsarlos de esta zona
los pastores ya no pueden cuidar
libremente su ganado en las montañas los
habitantes de aquí se sienten aislados y
abandonados por las autoridades iraquíes
y kurdes
y terminamos en Reino Unido porque el
museo horneyman de Londres devolvió a
Nigeria piezas que fueron saqueadas por
soldados británicos en el siglo 19 las
autoridades de Nigeria esperan que el
gesto sirva para presionar a otros
museos a tomar la misma decisión
particularmente al museo británico Juan
Pablo lucumí con los detalles
un pequeño museo al sureste de Londres
comenzó el proceso oficial de devolución
de elementos saqueados a Nigeria se
trata de los bronces de Benin uno de los
artículos más preciados para el país
africano arrebatado por la corona
británica la devolución es la respuesta
a la petición de la Comisión Nacional de
museos y monumentos de Nigeria la acción
es recibida como un gesto de moral
apropiada para las autoridades
nigerianas
creo que si la mayoría de museos ahora
están involucrados en la repatriación de
los objetos saqueados porque los otros
museos están simplemente observando
sentados allá afuera si ven que esto
está sucediendo en la mayoría de museos
importantes de todo el mundo Entonces
todos los demás deberían devolver los
objetos saqueados según los registros
los artefactos fueron incautados en 1897
durante una incursión militar británica
junto con otros miles de artículos y
terminaron en museos de Europa y Estados
Unidos El acuerdo entre ambas partes
asegura que seis de los artefactos serán
repatriados en Nigeria mientras 66 de
ellos permanecerán en calidad de
préstamo en el Museo de orliman en
Londres el consenso abrumador fue que
los objetos habían sido saqueados y como
tales deben ser devueltos sobre la base
de que fueron adquiridos por la fuerza y
bajo coacción las autoridades nigerianas
esperan que estas devoluciones aumenten
la presión sobre el museo británico de
Londres el cual posee por mucho la
colección más grande y significativa de
bronces de veneno
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Francia 24 y 34.com
[Música]